翻訳: Riaki Poništ
校正: Natsuhiko Mizutani
すごく眩しいですね
皆さんこんにちは
本間と申します
パンフレットの姿と
ずいぶん違うとは思うんですが
今 絶賛社会復帰中でございます
「アフター・インターネット」
このテーマで僕の頭に浮かんだ言葉は
「消費」という言葉でした
「費やして消す」と書きます
今僕たちは
毎日を生きるうえで
食べ物、情報
モノでもいいし、お金でもいい
色んなものを消費して
生きていると思います
インターネットは
その消費を大きく加速した側面が
あるのではないでしょうか
例えば情報でいうと
タイムラインが分かりやすいですね
どんどん情報が流れていく
一瞬で消費されて消えていく
情報だけではありません
色んなものがこの社会の中で
どんどん消費されて
そのスピードは加速してきている
今僕らはそんな世の中を
生きていると思います
でも「そろそろ消費に飽きてきているなぁ」
っていう感覚を
僕は持っています
皆さん どうでしょうか
消費じゃないものを求めている
なんかもう少し・・・
流れていくんではなくて
一回立ち止まってみて
その価値を再発見してみたり
もしくは自分で小さなものでも
作り出してみたり
流れていくものではなくて
もっと手ざわりがあって
においがあって
温度があるような
そんな価値を求めている
そんなことはないでしょうか
今日僕は
この「消費」というところから
何か抜け出すというか
新しいところに行くための
手法・考え方みたいなものを
皆さんにご提案したいと思います
それが ご紹介いただきました
「ソーシャルトラベル」というものです
旅です
旅行です
旅や旅行は買い物をするとか
新しいところに行って
おいしいものを食べるとか
何かアクティビティや
エンターテイメントをする
実はけっこう「消費」的な活動だと
思うんですよね
ただ そんな「旅」の領域でも
消費から抜け出した
新しいことができる
そういったことを僕は体感して
そして今広げる
そんな活動をしています
名前をつけるとするならば
「消費する旅から
創り、守る そんな旅へ」
これが「ソーシャルトラベル」です
ちょっと僕の体験談を
始めさせてもらおうと思います
大学を卒業して
４年ぐらい
大きな企業で僕は勤めました
誰もが知っているような会社
15万人のうちの１人でした
頑張って働いて
次に 友人と一緒に
ベンチャー企業を立ち上げました
４年ぐらい やりました
非常に成長もして
やりがいもあって
お金もそこそこ回りましたし
なかなか充実していた
毎日だったと思います
30歳のときでした
「でも何かが足りないなぁ」と
何かが足りないなという思いから
なぜか妻と２人で
世界一周旅行に行こうと
いうことを決めます
そのときは僕は「飽きる」とか
そういう言葉を使ってなかったんですが
おそらく何か飽きていたんだろうなと
「なぜ旅？」って言われても
答えられません
そこではない場所に行きたかった
それだけなんですね
２年 旅をしました
ここに見えているような国
主にインド、アフリカ
南米だと思ってください
そういった国に行ってみたくて
旅をしました
旅のテーマはこんな感じです
[遺跡よりもいま 絶景よりもひと
遊びよりも生活]
遺跡だとか絶景とか
色んな所に行って
色んな遊びもしました
すごく楽しい
そんな旅行もしましたけれども
僕はもう少し「今」—
遺跡っていうのは「過去」ですよね—
そして「景色」よりも「人」
「遊び」よりも何かその日々の「生活」
そんなものにフォーカスするような
旅をしたいなと思って
旅をしていました
毎回 新しい町に行って最初にすることは
妻が荷物を見ている間に
僕が町中を歩いて
居候先を探すんです
誰か泊めてくれる奴いないかなと
片っ端から声をかけて
居候が一番楽しい
一番現地が分かる
一番今の人の生活が分かるということで
そんな旅をしていました
すべて成功したわけではないんですが
そんな旅をしていた
それはそれで
すごく最高だったんですが
旅を始めてから
４カ月ぐらい経ったときに
インドのある村で
１つの大きな
ターニングポイントを迎えました
なんか理由はまったく覚えてないんですが
この子たちが可愛いくて
ある村にあったんですが
毎日30分ぐらいかけて歩いて行って
この学校に通い始めました
インドの学校いいですよね
“Hi, I'm Japanese!”
って言っていきなり入って
“I want to teach English”
って言うと
なんか知らないけど
教えさせてくれるっていう
日本だったら
つまみ出されるようなことができる
（笑）
そんなこともあって
学校で英語を教えたり
サッカーを一緒にやったりして
名前を覚えられるようになって
僕も名前を覚えて
名前で呼んで
そんな楽しい毎日を過ごしていました
この学校には
机と椅子がありませんでした
みんな地べたで
一生懸命書いて やってて
単純にかわいそうだなというか
なんか背中大変そうだなと思ったんで
妻と話して
机と椅子をあげたいね
という話になりました
僕ボランティアとか
社会貢献とか寄付とか
すごく苦手で
まったくしたこともなかったんですが
今回 このとき
すごく自然にそう思えたんですね
ただ お金はない
僕はバックパッカーだったので
じゃあどうしようって
町のカーペンター
大工さんに話をつけて
机と椅子だと高いけど
ベンチにしたら安くなるとか
工夫をしながら
大工さんと一緒にトンカンやったり
子どもたちと一緒に
ペンキを塗ったりしながら
机と椅子をプレゼントするということが
３、４万円の予算で
することができました
200人ぐらいの学校でした
すごく感動しました
すごく楽しかったし
先生も、生徒も、地域のコミュニティーも
みんな喜んでくれました
そのとき僕は気づいたんです
旅人とは風の人です
いつどこに行くか分からない
時間も予算も限られている旅人でも
地域やコミュニティに
貢献することって
できるじゃん
これが僕の見つけた
ソーシャルトラベルという形でした
限られた予算の中でも何かしよう
何かアクションをしようよと
カーペンターと話してますね
このインドでのプロジェクト
その他にも その後
インド、アフリカ、南米
色んなところで
色んなプロジェクトをしました
例えば ネパール—
お隣のネパールでは
女性のカースト問題に取り組む
ある女性社会起業家の方にお会いして
その方が作っているプロダクトを—
ブログを書いてたんですが—
ブログ上で売ってみようと
妻が言いだして
そんなの無理だと思ったんですが
とにかくやってみました
１週間で30万円売れました
それで １個ミシンをプレゼントして
新しい雇用が１個生まれる
そんなことがありました
マラウイ—
アフリカはマラウイです
アフリカに行くと皆さん
すごくビックリすると思います
あの平日の真っ昼間から
若者が町で酒飲んでるんですよ
あれは異様で
すごく衝撃的な風景でした
何なんだと
職がないんですね
何で働かないんだと
いやガバメントが何たらだと
何かもうムカついたんですね
「お前働けよ」と
これですね
ノートブック作ってるんです
メモ帳を作っているんですけど
僕らがそのとき
そこでやったプロジェクトは
「こいつらを働かせる」
というプロジェクトだったので
「わかった
俺らみたいなツーリストに売れる
プロダクトを一緒に作ろう」ということで
彼らは 昼間から飲んでる
バーみたいな所で
紙パックで
ドブロクみたいな酒飲んでるんです
そのパックを使って—
可愛いデコレーションだったんで—
これ ちょっと見づらいんですが—
青と赤の可愛いデコレーションなんで
「じゃあ これを使って何か作ろうぜ」
と言って
彼らが考え出したアイデアが
このノートブックだったんです
中をちょっとピッとやって
書けるようにしたり
しかもウォータープルーフだとか言って
名前も良いんです
「ドリンク&スウェット」
ドリンクした後
スウェット 汗をかく
そんな 小粋な名前も考えてきました
何十個も作って本当に売ってました
すごく ちっちゃなインパクトなので
何かこう社会貢献をしたとか
そんなんじゃないんです
でも旅人でもなんか
こういうことできるんだな
めちゃめちゃ楽しいと
そういう経験をしました
整理するとこんな感じでしょうか
[眺める→飛び込む→行動する]
まず普通の旅
もしくは旅行といわれるものは
「眺める」みたいなところが
あるんじゃないかなと
言い方を変えると
自分のコンフォート・ゾーン
心地のいい所からあんまり出ない
そんな中で
「消費」的にお買い物したり
リゾートに行ったりとか
これをまったく
否定するものではないんですが
ソーシャル・トラベルについては
もう幾つかステップがある
次に「飛び込む」
現地の人と一緒に
食べて、寝て、起きて
色んな生活をする
そのときのルールがあります
評価をしないということです
「絶対違います」
「絶対臭い」
「絶対心地悪い」
そういうことは起きるんですが
それを「違い」としてリスペクトしていく
そのときに あなたは
コンフォートゾーンから外に出て
現地に溶けこんでいると思います
トランジットという言葉が僕は好きで
自分がトランジットして
現地化していくみたいな
そんな感覚の旅っていうのが
次のステップだと思います
そして最後のステップが「アクション」
「行動する」っていうことですね
自分で考える—
「何かできることはないか？」
例えば色んなNGOだとかが
ボランティアプログラムを提供してます
そういうのも すごく素晴らしいし
僕はただ行ったことがなくて
なんかこう自分で考えて自分でやる
小さくてもいいからやるっていうことが
すごく好きでした
それがソーシャルトラベルというものであり
そうすることによって
かけがえのない出会いが生まれて
そこからどんどん転がるように
色んなことが起きていく
何かを守って作り出す
そんなことにつながる旅だと思っています
僕は 僕と妻の２人だから これができたとは
まったく思いませんでした
このソーシャル・トラベルみたいなことは
もっと広く みんなに
やってもらえるものなんじゃないかと思って
始めたのがソーシャル・トラベル合宿
インドを舞台にしたので
“Feel India”というものです
毎年10人ぐらいの参加者が
来てくれるんですが
ルールは簡単です
来てもらいます
僕は現地に色々つながりができたので
現地の村の人だとか
学校をやっている人だとか
いわゆるソーシャルワーカーといわれる—
社会的アクティビティをしている人を
とにかく紹介します
そこまでです
「予算５千円ぐらいで１週間の期間で
なんかやろうぜ」
“Do your project!”ということを
無茶ブリするという企画です
こんな企画
来る奴いるのかと思ったんですけど
毎回来るんですよね
頭おかしいんじゃないかと思うんですが
なんか来るんです
彼らがやってくれてきたことが
いっぱいあるんですけども
幾つか紹介します
学校を作りました
インドの村に行くと
場所にもよるんですが
「ここには学校がない
子どもたちには学ぶ場がないから
ドネーションしてくれ」とか
「学校作りたいんだ
100万円あれば校舎が建つ」
そういうふうに声をかけられることは
すごく多いと思います
僕は応じたことはないんですが
参加メンバーの１人が
そういう要請を受けたときに
「お前ら 校舎 校舎言う前に
木の下の学校から始めろ」と
聞いたら 教師の給料は
2000円ぐらいだったんですよ 月に
「おお じゃあ
３カ月やっても6000円か
バジェット内でいけるじゃないか」
ということで
学校をつくるという提案を
現地の人と一緒にやったんですね
ここはさらに深い村だったので
本当に学校もないし
外国人なんか
来たことないような所でしたけれども
こんな企画になって
ホントかよって思ったんですが
二人組のチームでやってたんですが
実際にやってのけました
100人ぐらいの生徒が開校式に来て
これ実は僕がいなくなった後
送られてきた写真だったんですけど
びっくりしましたね
「おお！」と
「教師の面接も終わりました」と
「どこまでやってるんだ」と
でも 彼らは
そんなことをやってくれました
そしてこの学校は今も続いています
３年以上前のことです
次の年に行ったときには
屋根を直そうって言って
これもまた予算がないので
すごく手作りな感じですけど
屋根を直すみたいな
プロジェクトをしました
あと すごく良かったのが去年
「運動会をやろう」と
体育の授業もない
運動会なんかない
じゃあ やろうじゃないかという企画を
立ててきてくれた人がいて
ちなみにその人は
海外初めて という人です
地元の この村の長と話をつけて
夜なべして ハチマキ作って
メチャメチャ盛り上がりましたね
こんなに盛り上がることあるのか
本当に村じゅうの人が来てくれて
子供向けのアレだったんですが
400人ぐらい
村の人が来てくれました
こんなソーシャルトラベルを
自分でやって
みんなともやってっていう中で
僕自身の旅も続いていきました
2011年に２年の世界旅行を終えて
帰国した僕らは
東北に行きました
ご存知の通り2011年3月に
震災があった東北です
10月でした
僕らが行ったのは
そこでまた何か出会いがあって
何かしたいなっていう
旅人もしくは
ソーシャルトラベル魂がうずいて
幾つかのプロジェクトを立ち上げました
その１つが一番左にある
『東北復興新聞』という新聞の発行であり
それの延長として
書籍を発行することもできました
また 別の人と出会って
今一緒に食べ物付きの雑誌
『東北食べる通信』というような
プロジェクトもやっています
気づいたら
僕は旅をしている—
ソーシャルトラベルをしているだけの
つもりなんですけれども
３つのNPOの理事であったり
代表理事として 今 活動をしています
そんなの普通できるわけないと
言われるんですけど
ヒントがあります
こうやったらできます
例えばアフリカに行ったときのことでした
インドやネパールで色々できたので
「よしアフリカでも何かするぞ」と
僕らは旅をしていて思って
勇んで行ったんですが
アフリカですごく怯んでしまいました
根が深いなと
“Hi!”って小学校に入っていって
英語のクラスをやるのとはレベルが違う
そもそも貧困の問題だと
政治が腐敗しているからじゃないかと
マクロデータ的には
こういう数字が出ている
こういうふうに実はあるべきなんだ
っていうものを考えた途端
足がすくんで手がすくんで
何もできない
そんなことがありました
さっきのアフリカのプロジェクトは
BoobsとLemon Squeeze
という二人組のチンピラが
なんか可愛くて
「お前ら 働け！」って言って
始まったプロジェクトなんです
そうではなくて
僕らがアクションに結び付けられたのは
「何でこうなるんだろう」とか
「こいつ なんか好き」
「こいつを応援したい」
そんな気持ちから
たった１人のためだけに
始めたプロジェクトでした
東北もそうです
東北で今やっていることの全てが
たった１人との出会いで
東北のときはこんな言葉です
「あんたの夢 乗った！」
「この人と一緒に夢を追いかけたい」
という人との出会いが
僕は 小さな でも確かな一歩に
つながっていったなという風に感じています
先ほどのネパールの社会起業家の女性の方
普通にショップやってるんですよ
死ぬほど同じようなショップが
あるんですけども
なんか目に止まって入って
一瞬会った瞬間—
タラという女性なんですが—
この女性の目に惚れちゃったんですね
僕と嫁 ２人で
彼女のためだけに何しようって
その夜 中華料理屋行って
ソバ食いながら
アイデアを出して出てきたのが
ブログで売ろうというプロジェクトでした
１人から始める
そういうことが
一番の“key”だなと思っています
最後になります
「消費」
これがキーワードだと最初に申しました
「消費」の反対は「生産」
もしくは「創造」というものだとも
言えるかもしれません
何かを生み出す
何かを作り出す
一人ひとりが
小さくても そういったものに—
作り出していく
生み出していくようなほうに
転換する シフトしていくことが
これから必要なんではないかと思っています
でも簡単ではない
そんなあなたに贈るツールが
ソーシャルトラベルです
日本だと、東京だと、北海道だと
しがらみありますよね
なんか恥ずかしいとか
失敗したらどうしようとか
しょうがない
そんなもんです
インドに行きましょう
インドでは誰も
あなたのことを知りません
ネパールに行きましょう
アフリカに行きましょう
そこで何かアクションしてもいいかも
っていう気持ちになりますから
騙されたと思って行ってください
そこであなたがする—
あなたが出会う
たった１人と一緒に作る
ソーシャルトラベルが
消費から生産・創造する
そういった気持ちを
シフトさせる鍵になると信じています
ご清聴ありがとうございました